so what is one thing that could
transform your life your marriage your
company your church but that you almost
certainly are not doing hint it's about
how you approach failure welcome to
Table Talk where I unpack ideas and
insights from Christian theology
spirituality and culture that help you
become a more thoughtful calm and just a
wonderful human being my name's Brett
pastor at the table and sexy Texas and
let's go ahead and jump into our talk
for today so a few months ago my dad
suggested a book it's titled
black box thinking why some people never
learn from their mistakes but some do
it's written by Matthew saiad and it's
really not so much a book about like
religion or spirituality though of
course as always I saw many connections
instead it's a book about failure in how
so much of our success in life whether
in our job or as a parent or heck maybe
just our general success at living a
meaningful and joy-filled life is based
on how we respond to failure now of
course this is somewhat common knowledge
like I can hear you saying yes yes I
should learn from my mistakes
only here's the thing almost no one is
doing it why because for our small
failures it's a little painful and for
our big failures it hurts like heck or
hell or whatever you wanna say it really
hurts I mean like face it first off who
on earth wants to admit to themselves or
others yep I failed really missed that
one
no one second off who wants to take the
time to reflect on why it happened and
why they need to change again almost no
one but saiad are used that's the secret
sauce yeah this brings up the question
Oh Bret it's so painful maybe it's just
not worth it well that's what I found so
compelling about this book because saiad
gives example after example of how
people and organizations who basically
took the time to review their failures
versus actively covering them up
explaining them away just flat-out
pretending like they didn't happen how
they get so much better at what they do
the classic example he gives in his book
he comes back this over and over is the
contrast between the aviation industry
and the healthcare industry
so in aviation they have an entire
system designed to learn from their
failures in fact pilots stewardesses
other crew members are all encouraged to
report mistakes even on themselves
without fear of punishment at least as
long as they do it quickly they can't
come clean ten years later so they do
this in order to ensure that the entire
system of aviation is constantly
learning perhaps you've heard of the
little black box that's on every
airplane this is where saiad gets the
name of his book so it's it's basically
the box that records all the vital
information of a flight it's the one
investigators attempt to retrieve after
a plane goes down to learn what the heck
happened right it's a system that learns
from failure and because of this the
aviation industry had basically it has
about three billion customers worldwide
each year and in 2013 only 210 died now
contrast that with the health care
system that does not treat failure this
way I mean generally speaking hospitals
doctor offices these are not places
where they systematically study their
failures why not because doctors are
nurses or whoever are uniquely bad
people of course not but because they're
human and again it's painful who wants
to admit they could have saved that
patient's life if all
they done procedure X instead of
procedure why who wants to claim that
they in fact administered the wrong drug
to the patient I mean come on like they
they would lose their reputation they'd
probably be fired but sayad points out
that partly because of this mindset in
the United States alone somewhere
between 40,000 to 120,000 people die
each year to preventable medical error
now of course this talk today this is
not about aviation and health care and
said what I'm encouraging you to do is
begin to approach failure in your life
your relationships your organization
more like the aviation aviation industry
unless like the health care industry now
having said that on a practical level
what do you need to do saiad suggests
two things number one we need a mindset
shift that recognizes look I am going to
fail my way to success so I don't need
to run I don't need to blame ignore or
protect my fragile ego in this process
you can see the connection there between
this book in spirituality no no need to
protect my gentle little full self
instead I need to recognize that the
world is incredibly complex and because
of this I will constantly be bumping up
against things that I did not see coming
also I am NOT God so I'm gonna mess it
up like we've got to embrace that
recognize it
relax into it so that's the first thing
mine said I need a mindset that
understands I'm going to fail my way to
success there is no other way
second we need systems seiyya
are used to help us analyze and learn
from failure for organizations this
might mean a brutally honest meeting at
the end of each project asking all right
well what did we learn and to be clear
this mean is not about patting each
other on the back or making excuses for
why we screwed up it's about learning
from our failures for exam
at my church the table we have a weekly
follow-up text or an email strand with
each of our ministry teams where they're
just following up on the Sunday service
and it basically asked the the leader
asks the team what went well what went
wrong and I have told my leaders like
encourage people to name the things that
go wrong because the tendency is just a
Pat each other on the back oh this is a
great Sunday everything was flawless cuz
we're perfect it's like no right so we
actually as a leader you have to give
them permission to be honest
so that's one way that we do it as an
organization now for an individual this
might mean like a nightly journaling
routine at the end of the week you might
do a what did I learn reflection session
for a family it could be a things we're
learning conversation your monthly
things were learning conversation the
point is that you need structure systems
intentionality around this so that you
discipline yourself to learn because
having a mindset alone won't be enough
all right so all that to say black box
thinking by Matthews I add it blew my
mind I highly recommend it so that is
all for today if you enjoyed this video
please like it comment share it with a
friend and to ensure you don't miss any
future episodes go ahead and subscribe
to my youtube channel by searching Brett
Tilford grace in peace